The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, guys.
So let's get started.
Welcome back from what I
hope was an exciting holiday
for everyone.
So today we're going to talk
about user authentication.
So the basic challenge that
we want to address today
is how can human users prove
their identity to a program?
In particular, the paper that
was assigned for today's class
addresses an
existential question
in the security community.
Is there anything better than
passwords for authentication?
So at a high level it seems like
passwords are a terrible idea.
So they have very low entropy,
its very easy for attackers
to guess them.
Also the security
questions that we
use to recover
from lost passwords
often have even lower
entropy than the passwords
themselves, which also
seems like a problem.
And even worse, users typically
will use the same password
across a lot of different sites.
So that means that the
vulnerability in one password,
if it's easy to guess, could
expose a user's activity
across a wide range of sites.
So as the paper for
today's class states,
I love this quote, "the
continued domination
of passwords over
all of the methods
of in-user authentication
is a major embarrassment
for security researchers."
All right, so the community
just seething out there,
they want some
better alternative.
But it's not clear
if there actually
is an authentication scheme
that actually totally dominates
passwords, that's more usable,
that's more deployable,
that's more secure.
So in today's lecture, we'll
basically do three things.
So first of all,
we're going to look
and we're going to see how
current passwords can work.
Then we're going to talk
about the desirable properties
at a high level for any
authentication scheme.
And then we're finally going to
look at what the paper gives us
in terms of metrics for
authenticating authentication
schemes, and we're
going to see how
some of these other
authentication
schemes actually
compared to passwords.
So in [INAUDIBLE]
what is a password?
So a password is a
secret that is shared
between a user and a server.
So the naive implementation
of a password scheme
is to basically
just have a table
on the server side that
essentially just maps
user names to passwords.
That's the simplest
way for you to imagine
implementing one of the
authentication schemes-- user
passes into their user name
and the password, server
network does a look
up in this table,
compares the password
of the client supplied,
what's in here.
If everything's good,
the user's authenticated.
So clearly the
problem with this is
that if the attacker
compromises the server,
then he can just
look at this table
and then get all the uses
passwords in the queue.
So that's clearly a bad thing.
So perhaps an
improved solution is
to have the server store
a table that looks like.
So once again, it'd
match the user name
but now it actually match
to hash of the password.
So user client's gonna
supply their clear text
password to the
server, the server
will then take that
clear text password,
hash it, do look at the
table, and once again see
if the user is who he or
she says that they are.
So the advantage
of this scheme is
that by designed
these hash functions
are difficult to invert.
So if this table is
lost, it's leaked somehow
or the attacker
compromised the server,
and the attacker could
look at these things here,
but it's difficult
for the attackers
to say, OK, this sort of
string of random alpha
numeric characters here.
Here's a pre-image that
was used as the input
of the hast function
[INAUDIBLE] that value there.
So that at least
is the nice thing
about these hashes in theory.
Now in practice,
attackers don't actually
have to launch
brute force attacks
to figure out what the preimages
for these hash values are.
So attackers can actually
take advantage of the fact
that passwords in practice
have skewed distribution.
And by skewed
distributions, I mean
that-- let's say that we
knew that all passwords were
20 characters long.
It's not like users actually
pick passwords that's
sort of exist in all
places in that space of 20
possible characters.
In practice, people pick
passwords like 1, 2, 3 or todd
or things like this.
So in fact there's been
these empirical studies
of how passwords work
and a lot of times
these studies find things
like the top 5,000 passwords
cover about 20% of users.
So what that means,
in other words,
is that the attacker has
a database of those 5,000
passwords.
The attacker can
just hash those,
and then when the attacker looks
at this stolen password table,
can just see if one
of those things that
come from this 5,000 large
list match over here.
And so empirically
speaking, the attacker
would be able to recover about
20% of passwords that way.
And so, folks at Yahoo
found that passwords
have roughly 10 to 20 bits
of intricate, 10 to 20 bits
of randomness in them.
And that's actually
not that big.
So, for example, if you
think about what might
this hash function here be?
So maybe it's something like
shop, something like this.
So modern machines
actually calculate millions
of these hashes every second.
So the fact that hash
function by design
are suppose to be
easy to calculate
so it'd be fast calculate.
Combined with this
fact that there'd
be skewed password
distributions,
means that in principle, this
scheme here is not as secure
as it might seem.
So one thing you
can imagine to try
to make life more
difficult on the attacker
is you could imagine that you
use expensive key derivation
function.
And so by key
derivation function,
I just mean this thing up here.
This thing that's taking the
passwords as input and then
generate something that's
stored on the server.
So what's nice about
these key derivation
functions is it actually
have tunable cost.
So you can basically
turn this knob
and make that function
run slower or faster
depending on what you want.
And so the idea here
is that, let's say
that you're going to use
a key derivation function.
So assume these examples are
like PBKDF2, or maybe BCrypt
so you can look these up using
the miracle of the internet
if you care to know
more about them.
But the base idea
is let's imagine
that one of these key
derivation function
took a second to calculate, as
opposed to a few milliseconds.
That actually makes
the attacker's job
much more difficult. Because
when the attacker is trying
to, let's say, generate
values for these 5,000 topmost
passwords, it's going to
take the attacker much longer
to do that.
So does that all makes
sense how these things work?
Pretty straight forward.
So internally these key
derivation functions
often operate by repeatedly
calling a hash multiple,
multiple times.
So that's all pretty
straightforward.
So you might say, well,
does this solve the problem?
So can we just use these
expensive key derivation
function and be done with it?
So if this was a security
class, the answer is no.
So one problem is that the
adversary can build something
called rainbow tables.
And so a rainbow table
is basically just a map
of a password to hash out.
And so the insight here is that
even if the system is using
one of these expensive
key derivation function,
the attacker can calculate
one of these tables once.
It might be a little bit painful
because each key derivation
function indication is slow.
But the attacker can build
this table once and then use
that to crack all subsequent
systems the attacker can
break into that use that
same key derivation function.
So that's how
rainbow tables work.
And once again, to
maximize the cost benefit
of building this rainbow
table, the attacker
could take advantage of the
skewed password distributions
I can see up here.
So the attacker might
only build a rainbow table
for some small set of
all possible passwords.
AUDIENCE: So salting makes
this much more difficult.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
yeah, that's right.
So we're going to get to salting
I believe in a couple seconds.
That's right.
So at a high level, if
you don't use salting,
rainbow tables actually
allow the attacker
to spend some effort offline,
calculate this table,
and then sort of
amortized the cost
of calculating that
table over breaking
many different
password databases.
So the next thing that we can
think about to improve things
is salting.
I swear that guy
was not a plant,
I will give you your
$20 after class.
So how does salting work?
So the basic thing
is you just want
input some additional
randomness into the way
that the passwords generated.
So basically, you want to
take this hash function
and you want to put some
salt in there-- which
I'll explain in a second--
and then the password.
And this is the thing that
you saw on the server side
in the [INAUDIBLE].
So what is this salt?
And you just think of it as just
a string, a long string that's
provided as sort of a first
part to this hash function.
So why is it better
to use this scheme?
And know that the
salt is actually
stored on the clear
text on the server side.
So you might be thinking OK,
well if that salt is stored
on the clear text
in the server side,
it seemed like a server can both
steal the table that matched
user names to passwords
and the attacker can also
steal the salt. So
why is that useful?
AUDIENCE: Because if you picked
the top most common password,
you can't just use it
once and find a new user.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
So basically what
this does is this
prevents the attacker from
building a single rainbow table
and then using that rainbow
table against all instances
of that hash function.
And so you can
basically think of this
as sort of uniquifying
passwords even if they
are the same, basically.
So this is what a lot of
systems do in practice, they
use this notion of salt here.
And so the best
practices for this
so you want to
choose a salt that's
long Because you're going to
essentially think of the salt
as adding more bits to
this pseudo-password right.
So more bits is always better.
And the other thing
you want to do to
is that whenever the user
changes his or her password,
you typically want to
change that salt too.
So one reason for that is
let's say that users are lazy
and they want to pick the
same password multiple times.
Changing the salt will
ensure that the thing that's
stored in the password database
will actually be different even
it that password's the same.
I think there was a
questions somewhere.
AUDIENCE: Why's it called salt?
PROFESSOR: I'm actually
not sure why it's called
salt, that's a good question.
I'm sure there's some
answer to this though.
It's like why are
cookies called cookies?
The internet will know
but I actually don't know.
AUDIENCE: Add some
[INAUDIBLE] to the hash number
hash [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There we go.
I'm glad that we're
getting this on film,
cause I feel this
how we're going
to get our Touring awards.
That's right.
I'm sure there's some
answer on the internet,
so I'll look that up later.
But does that all
basically makes sense?
OK so these approaches are
fairly straightforward.
So what I've assume so far
is that somehow the client
is transmitting the
password to the server.
But I haven't actually specified
how that transition's actually
going to take place.
So how do we transmit
these passwords?
So the first idea you
might have would be,
well, we'll just
send the password
in the clear over the network.
This is clearly
cartoonishly bad,
because then there could
be a network attacker who's
basically snooping
and seeing the traffic
that you're sending.
And let's see if we can
just take that password
right off the wire and
then impersonate you.
So we always start
with the straw man
before I show you the other
straw men, which of course are
also fatally flawed.
So first thing you
think about is sending
a password in the clear.
Another thing you
might think, which
would be a little
bit better perhaps,
is perhaps we send the password
over an encrypted connection.
And so we use some type
of cryptography here.
Maybe there's some secret
key or something like that
and that's what we
use to transform
the password before we send
it over the connection.
So at a high level,
encryption always
seems to make things
better, right?
Trademark.
But the problem is that
unless you think carefully
about how you're using things
like encryption and hashing,
you may not be getting
the security benefits
that you think you're getting.
Because, for example,
what if there's
someone who's sitting
between you-- the client--
and the server, this proverbial
man in the middle attacker,
who's actually snooping
on your traffic
and pretending to be the server.
If you send encrypted
data, you haven't actually
authenticated the
other end, then
you could still be opening
up yourself to problems.
Because if the client
just, let's say,
picked some random key,
sends it to some entity
on the other side who may
or may not be the server.
It is not the
server, [INAUDIBLE].
You are sending something to
some person, who will then be
able to get all your secrets.
And so similarly,
people might think well
what if I don't send
the raw password
but I send a hash
of the passwords.
That actually doesn't
give you anything
in and of itself either.
Because whether you send
the password or the hash
of a password-- I mean,
a hash of the password
has the same sort of semantic
power as the original password
itself.
If you haven't
authenticated the other side
if you haven't authenticated
the server or things like this.
So the basic point
with this discussion
here is just to stress the fact
that just adding encryption
or just adding hashing
doesn't necessarily
give you any additional powers.
If the client can't authenticate
who he or she is sending
the password to then the client
could be mistakenly divulging
that password with someone they
don't intend to divulged it to.
So perhaps a better
idea than these two
is to use what they call a
challenge response protocol.
And here's an example of a
very simple challenge response
protocol.
So let's say we've
got the client here,
and then you've got
the server over here.
So the client says,
hi, I'm Alice.
And then the server response
with some challenge seam,
some quantity that the
server got to pick.
And then the client
is going to respond
with the hash of that
server sent challenge,
and then you can concatenate
that with the password.
So at this point, the server
can take this quantity.
The server knows the
challenge that it sent.
And presumably the server
knows the password,
so the server can
[INAUDIBLE] this quantity
and see it actually
matches what the user sent.
So what's nice
about this protocol
is that if we ignore man in the
middle attacks for a second,
the server is now confident
that the user's actually Alice,
because only Alice would
know this password here.
And what's nice about this is
that if the server is actually
the attacker-- so
in other words,
if Alice sent this thing
to someone who's not
the person who she's
trying to authenticate to,
then the attacker still
doesn't know the password.
Because the attacker
got to choose C,
but the attacker doesn't
know what this is.
And so basically
for the attacker
to figure out what
the password is,
the attacker has to be
able to, once again,
invert these hash functions.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious,
how can you not make
a client do the hashing?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So let's see,
so your proposed scheme
is that the client side is
going to call this thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so instead
of setting the password,
and having the server hash
the password and check it,
the client would just
send the hash password.
PROFESSOR: The client would
just sent the hash password.
So there's a couple reasons.
So one reason, as
we'll discuss later,
is that there's going
to be things called
anti-hammering defenses right.
Anti-hammering
defenses is designed
to prevent a bad client
from continually asking,
is this the password,
is this the password?
So then as a result,
it's easier for things
to be on the server side
as on the client side.
But suffice it to
say, you can, in fact,
do the hash on the client side.
Using JavaScripts or
something like this.
But the basic idea
is that somehow you
have to have the computational
expense be very, very large,
because that's going to prevent
the attacker from just guessing
what the password is quickly.
Is there another question?
AUDIENCE: Well I just
wanted to point out
that if the client
does the hashing,
then it's [INAUDIBLE] because
your password is the hash.
PROFESSOR: So that's true.
AUDIENCE: So if
somebody get the table
from the server
[INAUDIBLE] using
it to hash they can log in.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, it gets a little
bit subtle sometimes
depending on who can
pick, for example,
these challenge values.
Because if client and servers
can pick challenge values,
so that makes it more or
less difficult for the client
to launch those
types of attacks.
So for example, like one
problem with this protocol
here is that
basically the client
doesn't get to inject
any randomness into this.
So you can imagine
that you can make
this protocol more difficult
for the server to invert.
If the client actually got
to choose some challenge that
was put in here, so you got the
server side challenge verses
the client side challenge.
But you're right about that.
Any other questions?
OK.
So yeah, so this segues is
discussion we're just having.
So even though to
break this, the server
would have to invert
this hash, the attacker
could still try to do one of
these brute force attacks.
So one way that we
can prevent the server
from doing these
brute force attacks
is to choose one of these
expensive hash functions
like we were discussing before.
Another thing, as
we just discussed,
is that you could actually
allow the client to,
for example, choose its
own client chosen challenge
over here.
And so that
essentially would act
as like a client chosen salt.
So that would essentially
make it more difficult
for the hacker
to do things like build
up a rainbow table.
Because note that if the
servers is the attacker here,
the server always can pick the
same challenge value again,
again, and again, allowing
to build the rainbow table.
But if when the
client responded back,
the client also
included some salt,
some client chosen
challenge that it included,
then they'll
prevent the attacker
from building one of
the rainbow tables.
So does that all make sense?
OK.
So yeah, one thing
that I mentioned
that might be useful
to do is implementing
these anti-hammer defenses.
And so anti-hammering defenses
are basically designed to rate
limit the number
of password guesses
that a bad client can issue.
Because the idea here is that
if you've got some clients who's
trying to launch one
of these brute force
guesses against
the password, you
don't want that client
to be able to sit there
in a tight loop and just
say, is this the password,
is this the password,
is this the password?
So one way we can
do anti-hamming
it just do that rate limiting.
So the server will
say, I will only
accept let's say three
password guesses per second
from any particular client.
You could also mention imagine
implementing timeouts here.
So maybe the client can issue
a bunch of password requests
in a row, but then after, let's
say, 10 of them are wrong,
the server says, OK
you got to hold on,
I will not accept any more
requests from you for,
let's say, 10 seconds,
something like that.
And so both of these
things are designed
for preventing
brute force attacks.
And so, for example,
like some smart cars have
these types of
defenses, some TPNs
have these kinds of
defenses to basically stop
against this brute force attack.
So why is it important
for you to use
these anti-hammering defenses?
Well one reason
why it's important
is as we discussed
these passwords have
so little entropy.
So because passwords typically
have so little entropy,
it's really important
to prevent the attacker
from just trying to cycle
through that low entropy space
very, very quickly.
So as you may be aware,
a lot of websites
have these format constraints
that push upon you
for your passwords.
They'll say things
like your password must
have a punctuation, it must
have a mixture of numbers
and letters, you must have
uppercase and lowercase stuff,
so and so forth.
And so what those constraints
are trying to get you to do
is they're trying
to get you to expand
the entropy of the password.
But what's problematic though
is that it's not really
these formatted constraints
that we should be caring about.
It's the actual entropy
of the password itself.
So it turns out even if people
were given these constraints--
like you have to use
punctuation, characters,
and stuff like that-- the
entropy of resulting password
is often quite low.
So for example, people
will often put punctuation
at the beginning or end.
Because they don't want to
be troubled to remember like,
do I have like a dollar sign
in the middle or something?
And so as it turns out, these
format requirements oftentimes
don't make dictionary
attacks much harder
for a sophisticated adversary.
And the reason is because,
basically, the dictionary
attacker can leverage
these observations
about how people
pick passwords even
in the presence of constraints.
So for example, if the attacker
knows that people typically
put punctuation at the
beginning or the end,
just incorporate that into
your dictionary attack.
And so an actually really
interesting website
you can go to that's
called Telepathwords.
And so what's neat
about this site
is that it has a
little text box.
So you can type a character
into that text box--
you're pretending that
you're entering a password--
and Telepathwords
will try to guess
what your next character is.
So as you type
additional characters,
it'll have a little drop
down box which says,
were you going to put this,
were you going to put this?
It will give you a
little blurb that says,
here's what I think
that you were going
to enter this next password.
So how does Telepathwords work?
So it basically has
a bunch of databases.
It has a database
of common passwords.
It also has a list
of popular phrases
that it's taken from websites.
And it also has this
set of heuristics
which describe common user
biases in picking passwords.
So for example,
one funny bias is
that people will
often-- when they
are forced with
these constraints
to say you must use punctuation,
stuff like that-- a lot
of times when they're picking
characters for the password,
they will use keys that
are adjacent to each other.
So in other words,
they'll be very small
edit distance in physical
space with respect
to edit distance in
the actual password.
So what a Telepathwords does
is it has the database here,
so when you type in things
it's running these models.
And it's saying,
statistically speaking,
here's the most likely thing
that you're going to type next.
So it's almost like auto
complete for passwords.
And so what's funny
is that this shows
once again that if you
have these constraints,
they actually don't protect
you that much if there are some
of these underlying a priori
distributions of things
that the attacker
can't leverage.
I think there was a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah so it seems
like if an attacker is
too sophisticated
that they could
try guessing like a bunch
of IP addresses and things
which only would prevent
hammering [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's very tricky.
Now that's a good point.
So anti-hammering
basically sounds well
what's the scope of the attack
that you're trying to prevent?
So if you're concerned
about distributed attackers
and a network system, it does
become very, very subtle.
And suffice it to say that
the notion of anti-hammering
or [INAUDIBLE] systems, and
also the notion of things
like clipfraud, for example.
So in other words,
how does someone
who's running an
advertising campaign online
determine if someone's
actually putting the link
and actually paying someone
for those clicks, verses
this is just spammer who
got some box just sitting
there clicking on stuff.
So suffice it to say
there's a lot of distributed
heuristics that try to
solve those problems.
And in many cases, it's
not a science, it's an art.
But your [INAUDIBLE] correct
and in the distributed setting,
things get much more
difficult. All right,
so does this all make sense?
AUDIENCE: What about the
cryptographic anti-hammering
defenses?
Most of the time you end up
sending a hash on the line
[INAUDIBLE] that when
you get out of it
is exactly what
you would get out
the password of the
hashable password?
I know there are
protocols like SRP
or there are some zero
knowledge protocols.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: That you
use in practice?
PROFESSOR: They do.
Those protocols
provides some stronger
cryptographic guarantees.
A lot of times they
are not backwards
compatible with current systems,
which is why in practice you
don't see them used a lot.
But yeah, there
are some protocols,
for example, that
allow the server to not
have any notion of
the password at all.
So there's some zero knowledge
type thing or whatever.
So those things do
work in practice.
But one of the things that this
paper says is very interesting
is that you basically go
through all these authentication
schemes and they say,
OK, here's passwords.
Yeah, they kind of suck.
Here's some other
things that are actually
much stronger on
security access,
but then they all fail on
deployability or usability
and things like that.
And so that's one of the
interesting and slightly sad
outcomes of this
paper that maybe
even though we have all
these much stronger security
for the protocols,
we can't deploy them
for some usability reasons
or some [INAUDIBLE] reason.
So that's just a fun
site to go to right.
So they claim that they
don't store your passwords
so you take them at their
word if you want to.
But it is very interesting to
just sit down and think like,
what password I generate?
And then type into this,
and see how accurate
it is in guessing what
the next thing will be.
It even covers things
like the popular heuristic
like take a popular phrase
that has multiple words,
and then only take the
first letter of each word.
So this thing is
very, very good.
Very, very scary too.
OK so that's Telepathwords.
And so one thing that
is also interesting
when you think about is
in your password scheme,
is it vulnerable to
offline guessing.
So this was a problem
that Kerberos before that.
And then also V5 without
this thing they call preauth.
So the basic idea is that in
these versions of Kerberos,
anyone could ask the KDC for
a ticket that would encrypted
with the users password.
So basically, the KDC did
not authenticate requests
that were coming from a client.
Now the thing that
the KDC would return
was, in fact-- there
are some set of bits
here that the KDC would return.
I'm sure you don't want to
think about this ugly set
of cryptographic
printers anymore.
But suffice it to
say, the KDC would
return this stuff
that was encrypted
with the key of the client.
That's what will come
back to the client side.
So the problem with this is
that because the server did not
check who was sending this
encrypted set of things to,
the attacker can basically
get this thing here and then
try to just guess what KC is.
Just guess that KC is some
value, try to encrypt this,
see if it looks reasonable.
If not, try to guess
another KC, decrypt this,
see if it looks reasonable.
And the reason why the attacker
can launch this type of attack,
is that this thing
here, this TGT actually
has a known format.
So it has things in
here like timestamps,
and it has things in here like
various link field would have
to be internally consistent.
And so that basically
helps the attacker.
Because if the attacker guesses
the KC, gets this thing here,
a decrypted thing, and
the internal fields
don't check out,
the attacker knows
that it picked the
wrong KC, so they
can go on and pick another KC.
And so, in Kerberos V5,
basically the client
has to send in this thing
that it sends over to the KDC,
it basically sends a time stamp.
And then this time stamp is
going to be encrypted with KC.
So this is sent to the
server, and the server
looks at this and validates that
before it will send something
back to the client.
So that gets rid of this
problem that any random client
can show up and just
ask for this thing here.
AUDIENCE: So is time stamp
recorded in the message?
So can't the attacker just give
this message and enforce it?
PROFESSOR: Let's see here.
So can't the attacker
get this message here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
encryption [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So you're thinking
where the attacker might just
spoof this, for example?
AUDIENCE: No, I just brute
force it and get KC out.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So in other words,
you're worried
someone could observe this.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So I
believe that this
is put inside an encrypted thing
that belongs to the server,
or the key belongs
to the server.
I think to prevent that
attack. [INAUDIBLE]
so don't quote me on that.
But you're correct
it's not, for example.
And if the attacker,
for example,
knew something that about
what the current time is,
roughly, that actually
is super useful.
Because then the
attacker can guess,
oh, time stamp should be
roughly between here and here.
And if it sees
it's in the clear,
it can do the exact same
attack that we had up here.
AUDIENCE: It's a little better
because the attacker has
to be in the middle, but
it's still susceptible.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
Well, yeah, that's
right, the attacker
has to be on the
network somewhere so
this [INAUDIBLE] stuff.
That's right.
So that's all, I'm guessing.
So another thing that's
important to think about
is password recovery.
So this is the idea that
you lose your password,
and then somehow you
have to go to the service
and you have to ask
for another password.
But before you
get that password,
you have to prove that
you are you in some way.
So how does that work?
How to do password recovery?
So what's interesting is
that people oftentimes
focus on the entropy
of the password itself.
But the problem is that
if the password recovery
questions or the
password recovery scheme
has little entropy,
that actually
affects the entropy of the
overall authentication scheme.
So in other words, the
strength of the overall scheme
is basically equal
to the minimum
of the password entropy in
the recovery question entropy.
And so you see this
actually play out
in a lot of rules scenarios.
There's a lot of famous cases,
like the Sarah Palin case,
where basically someone
was able to recover
her password fraudulently
because her recovery
questions were things that
any random person could find.
By looking at her Wikipedia
article, for example,
find out where she went to high
school and things like that.
And so often times these
password recovery questions
are not very good.
And they're not very good
because of a couple reasons.
So sometimes these things
just have very low entropy.
So if you have a password
recovery question that
is something like, what's
your favorite color,
the most popular answers are
going to be like blue and red.
Nobody's going to say like
off white, fuchsia, magenta.
So some of these
recovery questions
intrinsically are very difficult
to provide a lot of entropy
for.
The other problem is
that sometimes these
recover questions can be
leaked via social media.
So for example, if one
of the recovery questions
is what's your favorite movie?
So maybe this space there
is a little bit bigger,
but if intrinsically I
can go look at, let's say,
your IMDB profile,
your Facebook profile,
and figure out like,
oh hey, you literally
told me that's your
favorite movie,
this isn't super useful either.
And another problem--
this is actually
sort of the funniest
one-- is that the user
selected recovery questions
are often super weak.
So for example, people
have done a survey
of what some of these
recovery questions look like,
and sometimes users
themselves will
set recovery questions that are
things like what is 2 plus 3?
And so, at the time, the user's
thinking this is a big hassle,
we're going to have to use this.
But trivially most humans
who pass the Turing Test
can answer that
questions successfully.
And then therefore get
the users password back.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] like
using recovery passwords?
It's basically like you enter in
your name and maybe the subject
of some emails that you've
sent, like a small amount
of additional information.
But based on that,
in some cases they
can-- is security of
that kind of stuff then?
PROFESSOR: So I don't know of
any formal study like that.
Those things are
actually a lot better.
I actually know
this, because I was
trying to help a friend
go through this process.
So she basically lost
control of her Gmail account,
and she was trying to prove
that this was her account.
And so yeah, they would ask you
things like roughly speaking,
when did you open this account.
Roughly speaking before you
lost control of this account
to hesball or whatever,
who were some of the people
that you talked to?
And things like that.
And it's actually a
pretty laborious process.
What ends up happening is
that you're generally correct,
it ends up being much more
powerful than this stuff.
And so actually I don't know
of any formal studies of that,
but it does seem
[INAUDIBLE] much strong
than these types of things.
All right, any other questions?
Now we can get to
the paper for today.
So reading for today,
the author has basically
proposed a bunch of factors
that can be used to evaluate
these authentication schemes.
And what's really cool
about this paper, I think,
is that it basically tries
to say, look, a lot of us
in the security community
are fighting just
based on aesthetic principles.
Like, we should pick
this because I just
like the way that the curly
braces look in the proof.
We should pick this because
it uses a lot of math mode.
And so what they say is, look,
why don't we try to establish
some type of criteria?
Maybe some of the criteria
are a little bit subjective.
Let's just try to have
this taxonomy of ways
to evaluate the
authentication scheme.
And let's just see how these
various schemes stack up.
And so the authors basically
proposed three high level
metrics for evaluating
these schemes.
And so, the first
metric is usability.
And so, the base
idea here is how
easy is it for users to interact
with this authentication
scheme.
So they find a couple
interesting properties.
So for example, is
it easy to learn?
This basically just means is
this scheme easy to learn?
So some of these categories
are pretty straightforward.
Some of them actually involve
a little bit of subtlety.
But this one makes
a lot of sense.
And so if we look at passwords,
passwords pass this test.
Because everybody is used to
using passwords, so we'll say
they are easy to learn.
Another category is
infrequent errors.
So that means when
you are trying
to authenticate
the system, if you
are the actual user
in question, is it
the case that you can
often authenticate yourself
without generating errors?
And so, here the
authors say quasi-yes.
And so the quasi prefix is
one of the more entertaining
aspects of the paper,
because authors kind of
admit there's this element
of subjectivity to it.
So we can't necessarily say with
crisp precision yes, no, things
like this.
So the reason why
they say quasi-yes
is because, in general, you
can authenticate a password
successfully.
But we've all been in that
place where it's like 3 AM,
we're trying to log on
to our email server,
our mind's not in
the right place,
and we enter a bunch of
errors a bunch of times.
So they say quasi-yes for this.
Another category is
it scalable for users.
And so the basic idea
here is if the user has
a bunch of different
services that he or she wants
to authenticate to, does
this scheme scale well?
Does the user have to
remember some new thing
for each one of the schemes?
And so, for here,
the authors say no.
Because in practice, it's
very difficult for users
to remember a separate
password for every single site
that they go to.
This is one reason actually why
people reuse their passwords
often.
So another usability
property is easy recovery.
So what happens if you
lose your authentication
token-- in this case, your
password-- is it easy to reset?
And in this case, the
answer for passwords is yes.
In fact, they are probably
too easy to reset,
as we just discussed
a couple minutes ago.
So that's a yes.
And so another existing
one is nothing to carry.
So a lot of the more Barouque
authentication protocols
require you run
some smartphone app,
or you have some security
token or smart card or things
like that.
So that's a burden.
Maybe not with a
smartphone so much,
but having to carry around
one of these other gadgets is
probably a pain.
And so this is actually one
nice feature of passwords,
you basically only have to
carry around in your brain,
which is one that you
should have at all moments.
So that's basically what
usability looks like.
It is very interesting
in a high level
that a lot of times
these sort of factors
are given a little bit of a
short shrift in the community.
Security can be when people
are evaluating these schemes.
They say, oh, this thing uses
like a million bits of entropy,
and can only be broken by
the Death Star or whatever.
But then people
don't necessarily
remember these are actually
very important factors too.
OK so the next
high level category
that the authors use to
evaluate authentication scheme
is deployability.
So the base idea
here is how easy
is it to incorporate this system
in to current web services.
So one thing they
look at, for example,
is is it server compatible?
And this basically means
can I easily integrate
this scheme with today's
servers, which are based
around text based passwords?
And so since success here
is defined with respect
to passwords, passwords succeed.
So another metric is
browser compatibility.
Similar type of thing.
Can I use this scheme with
current off-the-shelf browsers
without having to install
plug-in, something like that?
Once again, passwords
win by default.
And another interesting
one is excessibility.
So can people who can use
passwords now, but maybe
have some type of physical
disability-- maybe they're
blind, or they can't hear well,
or they can't gesture well,
or things like that.
Can they actually
use this scheme?
This is actually
pretty important.
So once again, the
authors' saying yes.
It's a little bit weird,
because it's not clear
that all people with all
disabilities can use passwords,
but they say yes here.
So yes, so these are
three interesting things
to think about with
respect to deployability.
And the reason why this
deployability category
is so important is because it's
very difficult to get anyone
to upgrade anything ever.
I mean people don't even
want to reboot their machines
and get a new OS
update installed.
So it's very difficult that this
scheme requires usable changes
on the server to get
people on the server
to actually do different stuff.
This goes back to your
question, why don't we
use these better things?
Cause deployability
in many cases
is super, super
important to people.
All right, so then the final
category that we will look at
is security.
Right, so what kinds of attacks
can this scheme prevent?
So a lot of these
security properties
are resilient to foo.
I'll just shorten
that one of reds.
So is the scheme resilient
to physical observations?
So the idea here is
that an attacker can not
impersonate the
user after observing
them authenticate a few times.
So imagine that you
had a shoulder surfer.
So you're somewhere
in a computer lab,
someone's looking
over your shoulder,
seeing what you type in.
Someone's videotaping
you, maybe someone's
got a microphone listening
to the acoustic signature
of your keyboard and
trying to extract things
from that, so on and so forth.
So the authors say
that passwords actually
failed this test.
And that's because someone can
videotape typing in things,
they can pretty easily figure
out what letters you typed.
Or there's actually these
attacks where you can actually
listen to the acoustic
fingerprint of the keyboard,
and detect what was typed based
on what sounds that you hear.
So passwords are not resistant
to physical observation.
So another property is resistant
to targeted impersonation.
And so the base
idea here that, is
that is it possible for someone
who knows you-- a friend,
an acquaintance, a
spouse, a loved one,
a family member,
whatever-- to impersonate
you using their knowledge of
who you are and what you do.
So could your friend try
to pretend to be you easily
in this particular scheme?
So here the authors
basically have another one
of these quasi-yeses.
And they say quasi-yes
because they're not
aware of any studies which
show that if you know a person,
you're more likely to
guess their password.
So they say quasi-yes for that.
And so, note that resistance
is targeted impersonation.
This is where most
security backup
questions fail miserably.
Because if someone knows
something about you,
quite easily they can guess
your security questions
in many cases.
So then we have two categories
that involve guessing.
So the first one is resilient
to throttle guessing.
And so what this means is
if the attacker can not
issue guesses at line
rate, because for, example,
the server uses
anti-hammering mechanisms.
Is the scheme safe
against the attacker?
And so here, they say no.
And so the reason
why they say no,
is because in practice
passwords not only
have sort of low inherit entropy
because they're not that long,
but also they have that
skewed distribution.
And so what that means is
that even if the attacker is
throttled in some way,
typically the attacker can still
make good forward
progress and crack
a lot of people's passwords.
So they define another
guessing property
which is resistant to
unthrottled guessing.
And so this is basically
saying, suppose
that the attacker can issue
these authentication forgery
request as quickly
as he or she wants.
So in other words,
the attacker is only
limited by the speed
of their hardware.
So is the authentication
scheme resilient to that type
of attack?
And here maybe this answer's
also no, for the same reason
that the answer was no up here.
So basically passwords have
a very small entropy space
and they come
skewed distribution.
So that's all pretty
straightforward.
One interesting
one is resiliency
to internal observation.
So this means that
the attacker can not
impersonate a user like
intercepting that users input.
For example, by installing
a keystroke logger
on the keyboard that
the user's using,
and using that logger
to steal keypresses.
This also means, for
example, that there's
no way for network
attacker who's
observing the things that the
client sending over the wire
to use that knowledge
of the network traffic
to later impersonate the user.
And so here they say password
do not have this scheme.
And they essentially say
it's because passwords
are static tokens.
They don't change.
And typically static tokens
are vulnerable to replay.
So if somehow, for
example, an attacker
installs a keystroke logger
and gets your password,
then basically the attacker
can use that password
until it's either expired or
revoked or something that.
It you just replay
it again it'll
go into that authenticating
server on the other side.
So here, passwords
actually fail that test.
Another thing that we
talked about a little bit
in this class phishing.
So resilience to phishing
is another security metric.
And the base idea here is that,
if the attacker can simulate
a valid service-- for
example, by attacking the DNS
infrastructure or
something like that--
then the attacker cannot collect
credentials from the user,
then the attacker can then use
to pretend to be the user later
on.
And so this basically
supposed penalized sites that
do not strongly tell
the user, hey, I'm
this particular service, so you
can feel confident to give me
your credentials.
And so if here passwords fail
just because phishing sites
are very, very popular.
So passwords don't really
intrinsically provide
any protection against that.
Now the next two
are particularly
interesting in the context of a
large scale distributed system.
So no trusted third party.
This essentially
means that other
than the client and the
server, there's no one else
in the system that is involved
in the authentication protocol.
And so, that means that
there's no third party who,
if that third party
were compromised,
the entire integrity of
the securities scheme
might fall apart.
And so, this is actually
an interesting property
to look at because a lot
of authentication problems
would go away if we could just
store all our authentication
information in one place.
We just store it in one
place, it's very simple,
we don't have to remember a
lot of stuff on the client,
we just say, whatever
service you want to use,
you always go to
this one third party,
and that third
party will always be
able to of authenticate
you, and then
allow you to go on your way.
Now of course third parties are
problematic with perspective
of robustness right
because if you
have one of these
global third parties
that everybody trusts, if that
third party gets subverted then
perhaps the integrity
of all the sites
that use that third party to
authenticate all those sites
are potentially in danger.
So they say that passwords do
not have a trusted third party
because each user is forced
to have a separate password
for each site.
A related property is